[Music]
if an applicant does get an interview
how would you recommend they prepare for
that interview well first of all if an
applicant gets an interview
congratulations that's it
we usually interview about two
candidates for every spot that we have
so number one the word preparer is a
really good one if you've made it this
far and work this hard you know treat
this as it's an important part of the
process we do our unlike some other
schools we use our alumni for
interviewers and they are all around the
globe we try to match you with people
from your you know your country maybe
perhaps an industry that you're in if
possible currently in so they really
understand you and it's in two parts the
first half an hour is primarily
evaluative and then the last 15 minutes
it's a chance for you to meet someone
from the community so come prepared with
the mindset to do to do both in the
first part we're going to be it's a
behavioral based interview so the
stories that we were talking about
before come ready to tell them we're
gonna want to know about what you're
most proud of what was the context what
was the challenge what did you do how
did you do it and then what was the
impact so expect some probing around
those those stories and then on the
second part it's fun our community is so
tight you enjoyed my interview a lot I
would actually I had a great time yeah
and did you enjoy the interviewer I did
it's pretty expert actually it was
really good at really drawing stories
out of me rather kind of in like intense
questions and by the end of it I felt
that there was somebody that I'd really
gotten to know and somebody who was a
part of a community I was excited to be
a part of so the interview was actually
really great for me and getting excited
for school and that that's a wonderful
way to to help with the second tip that
last part of the interview is it's a
gift it's a chance to develop a
relationship come prepared with some
questions that you want to know about
Stanford obviously but see it is just
one one entry step to being a part of a
bigger community